and nearly three months ago India's
ambitious attempt at making space
history ended when its scientists lost
communication with the chandrayaan-2
spacecraft moments before he was
supposed to touch down on the moon after
a month-long search America's Space
Agency NASA now says it has located the
crash site thanks to an amateur
astronomer are from India the W reporter
Peter dark is here with more welcome
Peter so a space mystery solved by an
amateur space detective yeah it's just
like it's a really cool story this is
just a regular guy from India who
basically managed to do what some of the
world's leading space scientists
couldn't his name is sean mukha
Subramanya and he's a 33 year old
mechanical engineer and a
self-proclaimed space nerd so when the
Indian mission control lost contact with
the spacecraft he decided to join the
search and see if he could find it okay
so how did he do that well he did all of
it from his laptop from his home he
scoured satellite images that were
shared by NASA about a week after they
were released he tweeted what he
believed to be the crash site comparing
an image of the targeted landing site
before and after the spacecraft went
missing and so he flagged his findings
to NASA which then decided to take a
closer look we should see the images
right here again they compared
before-and-after images of the supposed
crash site and lo and behold if we zoom
in a little bit maybe you can see that
he was bought on you see it well zoom in
a bit more there it is it's that little
tiny white dot right there so I mean
really talk about looking for a needle
in a haystack
that is some serious nerdery so you must
be considered something about a hero
right now yeah I mean especially in
India which had a lot riding on this
lunar mission you know purely as a space
engineering feat this would have put in
a very exclusive club only three other
countries the US China and the former
Soviet Union have managed to pull off
these soft landings on the moon India
would have done that at a much lower
cost than
most other space missions about 140
million dollars that's even less than
the budget of most Hollywood
blockbusters right but they didn't
that's the part I didn't either and
that's the point it's because more than
just the budget it was also this was an
issue it had become a matter of national
pride especially for Prime Minister
Narendra Modi his BJP nationalist Hindu
party who really have been trying to no
sell India as a big player on the
national on the global scene that can
you know hold its own so landing on the
moon would really have been that
crowning jewel and you can imagine what
a punch and the national gut it was when
when that failed
so from Modi having an Indian you know
help at least locate the the crash site
that's been a way to say face even
though in the mission you know failed
pizza doll thank you for that